[Music]
one of other Studios in Hollywood it's
the Conan audience II Awards celebrating
excellence in the sitting and looking
arse here now is your host Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen for a night this
important I need to dress the part Bruce
do you mind perfect and look at this the
winners will all receive this
beautifully handcrafted audience the
award this one was made over four
minutes ago this is yours
they last for 40 minutes all right let's
get to it our first audience the award
is for the best impression of a
celebrity and the audience C goes to the
person in seat 5d for their impression
of the host of hardball Chris Matthews
[Music]
[Applause]
Jason
this next audience award is also for
best impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
7j for their impression of the Cowardly
Lion
[Music]
[Applause]
Finnick
the guy's gonna be waiting for me in the
parking lot the next audience II award
is also for best impression of a
celebrity in the audience he goes to the
person in seat 16e for their impression
of Rosie the Riveter
[Music]
[Applause]
we wouldn't have won World War two
without you this next audience award is
also for best impression of a celebrity
and the audience he goes through the
person in seat 19 P for their impression
of Argentina's version of Newman from
Seinfeld
the final audience award for the best
impression goes to the person in c8 d
their impression of a 1970s GI Joe
action figure
[Applause]
[Music]
some beard the next audience egos to the
person in seat 11k it's the word for the
audience member most likely to have
directions to Margaritaville
our next audience seaward goes to the
person in seat 8g it's the word for the
person who didn't know he had a stalker
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's gonna work out just fine and
now and now this is the part of the
audiences where I thank the wonderful
sponsors who helped make our studio
audiences show experience as special as
it can be
thanks to products like Edgar's Lee's
smile hooks just because you aren't
happy doesn't mean you can't look happy
Eckersley smile those the number one
choice of Conan's audience and Kim Jong
Un's family and finally Beckenbauer x'
seat spikes
yes Beckenbauer seat spikes when a
standing ovation isn't just appropriate
it's mandatory
[Music]
[Applause]
please you know every time I host this
awards show I put on an instant slip on
tuxedo with a little help from our
wardrobe departments Bruce Bromwich
there he is right there
I think it's time to take a fond look
back at all the times Bruce has helped
me slap on a tux Bruce if you don't mind
[Applause]
what are you doing down there
[Music]
because I was stepping on the jacket is
that
now this wouldn't wouldn't be an awards
show without a spectacular musical
number for tonight's audiences we have a
special treat and exclusive performance
from the original members of Cirque du
Soleil
this is their first time performing
together since 1984 this is special and
joy
[Music]
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]